et
on apportera l'amour de dieu à tous à
ceux qui souffrent et qui pense avoir
été abandonné dieu un projet pour nous
qu'est ce qu'il t'a dit de faire cette
fois
il veut centrer
je ne veux pas que le soyons pauvres
thury falwell et us a maintenant dieu à
une voie dans cette bagarre ni qu'on
maquille le programme des gauchistes des
homosexuels après tout on est tous les
mêmes faits de la même poussière et dieu
n'a créé aucun déchet c'est de la
dynamite cette femme
si tout ce qui regarde je vais doubler
leurs promesses pendant un seul mois
servir dieu ne devrait pas être une
opportunité pour gagner de l'argent
pourtant on ne fait de mal à personne
c'est une question
je veux simplement aimer les gens steve
est un malade du sida vous devez la
contre l'émir ça
le diable m'a rattrapé famille on
pourrait parler de sept ans plus tard
certaines personnes souffrent un tel
poids
qu'on ne peut rien faire à part les i
oui oui c'est moi
[Musique]